you know I am convinced really that
probably there's two or three factors I
think that you could say the number one
thing the number one's correlating thing
with success is what one of them is
integrity it's hard to be really
successful if your dadgum crook and
people say all the time a crooks get
ahead but that's just on TV I mean the
real world once somebody messes you over
you tell everybody nobody else does
business with them it's very difficult
and so really crooks don't get ahead in
a long run and they bounce around from
thing to thing the constant have to
start over on all the relationships and
contacts and everything else it's very
difficult integrity is one of them you
know the other one is is perseverance
people that are successful they're not
necessarily smarter than the people
matter of fact they're usually don't
have the high level GPAs that some of
those brilliant people have typical
millionaire has a GPA below 3.0 in
college
mine was a 297 and that 3 107 points
still pisses me off mister 3x3 107
points unbelievable still mad about that
but you know the typical millionaire
doesn't even have a 3.0 GPA it's not
it's not GPA it's not unusual brilliance
it's not you know they invented the next
toaster or a bread slicer or whatever
sometimes they do those things but you
know I know thousands of millionaires
probably know thousands of deca
millionaires I know at least a 20
billionaire's
personally and none of them are shiny
brilliant blow you away with their
intelligence people none of them are not
a one gods maybe a one or two but I mean
most of them are just like really him
most but we're such regular people is
unbelievable except they're not regular
people they don't quit their ability to
persevere to not be denied
- just keep after it -
action to claw the ability to push
through if there's just a high
correlation between that and success
perseverance Bible talks about it Romans
5 3 through 7 rejoicing in tribulations
because tribulations produce
perseverance perseverance hope and hope
is a gift of the Holy Spirit as hard
times make you learn how to hang on
they make you learn how to fight through
if you have a grandma or grandpa that
survived the Great Depression change
them didn't it change the way they
looked at things went to World War 2 the
greatest generation yeah the people
wouldn't quit I mean the average guy on
the street in those days wouldn't quit
the people built America
they wouldn't quit they would not quit
they wouldn't quit you couldn't stop
them when quit and here's
thinking about that it's not some kind
of lightning in a bottle God strike just
randomly dropped on certain people not
dropped on other people the ability to
not quit is a choice you choose just
choose I'm just going to keep going I'm
just going to keep going we're the third
largest talk radio show in North America
587 radio stations right now
Rush Limbaugh has 623 my friend Sean has
a few less than me but he has more
listeners than I have and he's number
two we're the third largest talk radio
show in North America no one else in the
402 my friend glenn beck's 378 stations
you know why we're in the number three
not cuz I'm a better broadcaster than
some of those other people I'm not even
that good at radio or any of people make
fun of me all the time because I'm
really sloppy all I did was for 25 years
I didn't quit I've outlasted a whole
bunch of people that were supposed to be
the biggest thing in radio I just
survived because I wouldn't quit so I
did it really it really isn't very
pretty it's just kind of ugly but it we
just did it we just didn't quit hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]